[Music]
so okay
popcorn naan buttered if it's dry
popcorn let's clean look at that I can
touch my pants and there's nothing there
but somebody introduced me to popcorn
the Raisinets if I'm like really feeling
myself take like a handful of both and
you just chomp it all up together and
it's crazy right I mean obviously it
depends on how the theater is set up
like look if you take my advice you go
sit two-thirds back right in the middle
I mean that's what I would do but anyone
seen Shazam will still love it from even
that front row you'll really like it I
would say anyone and everyone it's a
great date movie it's a great family
movie it's a great friends movie it's a
feel-good movie well there's some stuff
Oh like if you're really looking but
that's good you know I remember when I
was a kid not watching Goonies there's
just scarier stuff but beyond that
anyone and everyone it's really about
wish fulfillment a little kid in all of
us who always dreamt about being a
superhero
this kid gets that opportunity and now
this kid gets that opportunity to play
that kid getting that opportunity and
that's so dope hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
[Music]